welcome to philanthropy in action where
we uncover the
people who give their time talent and
treasure
change the world these are stories of
philanthropy I am Maxum thorne and I
teach philanthropy in action at Yale
University ingo Reichenbach is the vice
president from Yale University who's in
charge of all of our fundraising Thank
You Inga for joining us thanks for
having me and we also have these
wonderful dedicated and brilliant Yale
students with us I'd like to ask them to
introduce themselves starting with Joan
I'm Joan gasps I'm a senior from Dallas
Texas and I'm double majoring in
International Studies and women gender
sexuality studies hi my name is Leslie
bowl I'm a junior from Arlington
Virginia I'm a political science major
and I'm studying international
development hi my name is christina lee
i'm a junior from san jose california
and i study history hi my name is Robert
rich Nicki I'm a freshman from New York
City and I'm studying computer science
I'm Ellen bankson I'm a sophomore from
Richland Washington and I'm studying
Chemical Engineering I'm Carl Chen I'm a
junior from outside Los Angeles I'm
studying sociology thank you